Dr Zakir for your eloquent
presentation we all just heard Dr Zakir
NY present a cross spectrum of proper
spiritual economic social educational
legal and political rights given to
women in
Islam based on the Quran and S
Hadith now we have inshallah the more
interesting open question and answer
session this is your session your right
be you a man or a
woman this is your right to question and
challenge Dr Zakir NY on his matter
spoken or on the topic of the day
women's rights in Islam protected or
subjugated do feel free to ask without
any reservations I Dr Muhammad Nik for
this session I'm your
coordinator and I guarantee you your
right to ask but of course as per the
rulle set for better management and use
of the time available with
us I want you all to remember these
brief three or four points before you
put forward your question your question
should be on the topic
only it should be brief and to the point
only only one question at a time may be
put forward to the speaker for your
second question you have to go at the
back of the queue again and await your
turn three mics have been provided in
this vast ground one in the front on my
left for the gents the second in the
rare for the
gents and we have one mic in front of
the ladies section for the ladies to put
forward their
questions we would prefer
non-muslims to be given the first
preference to ask questions and if time
permits after that we would allow
Muslims to come forward on the mic and
put forward their
questions volunteers at the mics are
requested to kindly ensure the same
kindly state your name and profession
before putting forward your question to
Dr Zakir
night we can start first with the ladies
the questions would go in a clockwise
manner one there then we have the second
question on the mic here on my left and
the third question there and so on yes
sister assalam alikum brother zaker uh
my name is diali Tamar and I'm from from
Pune I'm working as an incident manager
with an
MNC I would like to accept Islam and I
would uh want you to help me to recite
the
Kalma Mah the sister diali she's from
Puna working in MNC and she wants to
accept Islam sister before you accept
Islam I would like to make sure that is
anyone forcing you to accept Islam
sister uh no brother I've been reading
about Islam since a year now so I
thought this is the best opportunity for
me m is anyone forcing you no is there
any economic pressure no is there any
physical pressure no because in Islam
forcing anyone to accept Islam is
prohibited in Islam number one it's even
prohibited in this country that's number
two but if someone wants to accept Islam
willingly no one can prevent you from
and inshallah as your desire is I will
read the Kalma and inshallah you can
repeat it sister
yes and I'd like to ask you before he
asking Kalma that do you believe that
there is one God yes do you believe that
idol worship is prohibited yes I do do
you believe that the last and final
messenger is Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him yes I do Mah sister so I'll
just recite theama and you can repeat
after
me ASU ASU Allah
Allah
illu Muhammad muhamad ABD
ABD I bear witness I bear witness that
that there is no God there is no God but
Allah but Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness that that Prophet Muhammad
prophet Muhammad is is is the servant
the servant and the messenger and the
messenger of Allah of Allah mashallah
sister you're a Muslim thank you and may
Allah subhana tala reward you and I pray
to Allah subh to Grant you Jenna it's
good that you have been studying Islam
for one year and it is good you read the
Quran and the Hadith otherwise if you
have seen the media maybe you have never
accepted Islam so I pray to Allah
subhana wa tala that may you accept your
effort and inshallah Grant you jna thank
you sister thank you thank you
yes
brother har Krishna my name is ravikant
Pand I'm 23 years old I have completed
my graduation from Kolkata University I
belong to sonat Dharma so I have no
qualification to speak in the front of
you but I'm trying to speak with you I
have one question in my mind and uh even
I I can speak wrong because I don't know
English very much well so please forgive
give me uh my question in sanata Dharma
is also
written woman should be protect in a
Child Time by his parents and a young
Time by his husband and after the mother
his Elder son will protect two men in
Sonata Dharma says there is no love in
this world is lust is there in this
world so love and lust is two different
thing and if you it cannot be go in a
same one platform so our real duty is to
engage the service of the Lord and in a
sanatan Dharma Arjuna asked one time to
Krishna oh Krishna please tell me what
this man are is speaking I don't know I
I don't know so many languages so please
clarify me so Krishna told to Arjuna
they are talking like a frog even a
snack come and they eat just like I come
by death and I eat so in this world
there is no love we are trying to
satisfy it this is a simply attachment
we can say in sanatan Dharma says woman
attached with a man and man attached
with a woman so uh this sanatan Dharma
because in bhagat Gita 5,200 years ago
came and 2,800 years ago in Bible came
and 1400 years ago your Quran came so
sanatan Dharma is coming by so many
millions of year so I belongs to I am
not justifying our life is meant for
simply engage the service of what's your
question brother I've read the sanatan
I'll give my comments on sanatan to you
I want to ask you what is the question
do you want to say the sanatan Hinduism
also protects the women no I am asking
so our life our duty is to satisfied the
woman or satisfied the Lord or engage
the service of the Lord the brother the
question question is our duty to satisfy
the woman or to satisfy Lord yeah the
brother has a question that what is our
duty to satisfy the woman there is love
there is lust or to satisfy almighty God
before I come to youran I will tell what
Islam says as Allah says in the Quran I
said my talk in Sur Room chapter number
30 verse number 21 that Allah subhana
tala is created for you made from
amongst yourself so that you may dwell
in tranquility and he has put love and
mercy between your hearts that means
Allah has created for you of your nature
mates your wives your spouses so that
you may dwell in them in Tranquility you
get Tranquility you get calmness and
almighty God has put love between your
hearts once our beloved Prophet malli
wasallam said that
even having
sex with your wife it is
Charity so sa ask even having sex is
Charity how so the reply came because
you are having it
lawfully if you have it unlawfully with
the woman who's not your wife it becomes
prohibited so because you're enjoying
lawfully even that is Charity that is
that's a good
deed so having sex with your wife also
almighty God rewards you and you rightly
said that there is love and there is
lust I to have read sanatan DH and
appreciate the Oneness of god mentioned
sanatan DH you know Hinduism has got
various different sects you may be aware
of that various different denominations
the highest scripture there is shti and
there smti shti according to Hindu
scripture means the word of God and vas
are the highest they believe in one God
they believe almighty God has got no
images I can give quotations you can see
my video cassette similarities between
Islam and Hinduism
but should we satisfy the woman or
should we satisfy God number one I said
in my talk the basic aim of every human
being whether man or woman should be to
satisfy almighty
God now while satisfying almighty God
you may satisfy the woman you may not
satisfy if she's a good Pious woman
she'll be satisfied if you are
satisfying almighty
God for example almighty God says have
sex only with your wife a pi woman who's
a most will be happy but a lustful woman
she will not be happy she will say why
you following God follow me she Mayan
she may be a footstep of the devil you
ask me questions about
Krishna that Krishna gave advice to
Arjun since you mentioned
Krishna he's supposed to be a role model
for the Hindus and we read in
Mahabharat you know I've given the talk
on similarity but because you asked this
question
what we read in Mahabharat that when
Krishna when he goes on the bank of the
river very often when the woman used to
go to have a bath he used to take the
clothes away and run away for
what For Love or for lust because he is
God he can do suppose I am honor of I if
God would like to Rob clothes of women
and none away to see them coming out
okay come out without clothes why can't
you and I
do if you can copy God why can't you
copy God if we see if you know this is
the
ultimate see we cannot copy God because
God is on a different level but if you
consider Krishna to be God and if God is
doing something like taking away clothes
of the woman and telling them come out
without clothes can you do that or not
you can do it very easily that's what we
find in Hindi movies you know we find
all this what I'm trying to say we
should take the message which is right
I've read the San DH there are many
things things which are good hundreds of
good things thousands of good things but
what is not good you have to leave it
aside I've given the talk on
similarities between Islam and Hinduism
now you speak about Krishna talk about
love talk about lust I appreciate many
things of Christian but not
everything many things he said is right
he tells that be a shatra fight against
Injustice even be against your
relatives he says that in bhagwad Gita
chapter number two verse number 31
same thing in the Quran Sur 4 135 that
stand out for justice as witness to
Allah subhana wa taala even if it be
against yourself against your relatives
against your father or mother Allah
protects SM so if what he's saying
matches with my Quran with the real word
of almighty God I accept it but
everything I don't accept it to be the
word of God that's the reason what I
do this is the
fan fan is the criteria to judge right
form wrong and if you read this this is
the last and final revelation of
almighty God which was revealed to
humanity if you read this I challenge
you to take out a single mistake in this
the other books that we
have the other religious scriptures
because of passage of time they have
been changed interpolation concoction
who says that not I the scholars of
Christianity they say that the Bible has
not been maintained in the true form the
scholars of maharat say that initially
Mahabharat was a story told by the
grandfather of Arjun to the people later
on the 8,000 shlokas became 24,000
shlokas now we have more than 100,000
shlokas interpolation addition so what
has been added I cannot accept that God
Almighty leave us at God even the
prophet of God can do such things so
what I say this may be an
interpolation I respect the messengers
of God but if you say that these people
people are saintly people no saintly
people will do what I consider Okay this
may be an interpolation this may be a
concoction so therefore I request you to
read a book which is 100% pure without
any interpolation Allah has promised in
the Quran in Surah chapter number 15
verse number n that we have revealed the
Quran and we shall Guard from corruption
almighty God has taken him upon himself
that he will prevent any corruption in
it from this if you read you get the
pure rights that the woman can have in
this world hope to answer the question
brother may we have the next question
from the Gen side in the
rare this is U Shar here I'm so grateful
to the irf that we get this opportunity
to ask you some questions and for the
first time I've uh seen you and I'm glad
that I can ask you a simple question I
am a
businessman and one of my rather my only
hobby is uh studying religions so one of
them obviously being the Quran so my
question is fairly simple like um I
really liked what you spoke about Aisha
that was a very uh wonderful thing that
you said so um my question is fairly
simple I'll make it very small but I
really hope that I have the opportunity
to cross question you after you answer
me on your
answer thank
you so uh we see in Muslim uh book
number four number
2127 wherein it says a part of it that
is uh he stuck me Aisha on the chest
which caused me pain uh further down if
you look at mishkat Al masabi uh Volume
2 page number 690 repeated again in
Muslim book number 9 number 356 a part
of it I'll just get to the point where
an Umar is trying to say to the prophet
or right rather trying to make him laugh
he says messenger of God I wish you had
seen the daughter of kija where she
asked me for extra money and I got up
and slapped her on the neck God's
messenger laughed and said they are
around me as you see asking for extra
money Abu Bakr then got up went to Aisha
and slapped her on the neck and Umar did
the same to haa now we see something of
a pattern coming in then U if you just
jump to Quran chapter 4 verse vers 34
and those wives you fear may be
rebellious admonish banish them to their
couches and beat them now as I
understand from your talk that there is
equal punishment for both man and woman
I'm not contending whether they should
be beaten or not my point is um what is
the right of the woman if the man is
wrong because he gets to beat her
up brother asked a very good question
and I give you the right to cross
question me after the answer it is
granted the brother quoted Hadith of
Muslim and
Mishi do you know the relationship
between H and Omar well I've not really
got to the point that much I'm still
studying do you know the relationship of
AA and Abu Bakr Allah with them both her
father if I'm not mistaken that's
right I'm asking you a question are you
married yes yes do you have a daughter
two of them two of them fine I get to go
to heaven sorry I get to go to heaven no
if you bring them up correctly I
remember with love and compassion then
you'll go to heaven otherwise not but
just kidding just kid but that is only
righteous without IM you can't enter
Jenna so for you to go to heaven besides
upbringing your two daughters correctly
you have to follow the laws of the Quran
and the and be a believer understand
that we'll discuss after answer to you I
understand after answer inshah I'm
asking a simple question suppose your
daughter if she wants to jump from a 10
story building what will you do I'll
stop
her is she adamant what will you do yeah
you get the point very good if she to
jump no I'm to go I want to fly like
Superman dad you are preventing me from
being a Superman what will you do well
I'll I'll stop her obviously will you
slap her or not if if if required she
saids no to jump what will you do
well I I can ask the other way around
what my wife I'm asking if you wants to
jump from the 10 story I will her if
required not Norm
you I want to fly one F father is cruel
to be kind yes now our beloved Prophet
wasallam said anyone who does not love
Allah and his messenger more than his
own life he's not a
Muslim
anyone who does not love Allah and his
messenger more than his own life he's
not a Muslim so there are many occasions
what happen that sometimes they were
disrespectful to the husband not a
normal husband Prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam there were many occasions not
one occasion there many Omar may Allah
pleas with him and hasz abak may Allah
please with him when they came to know
that one of the wives has caused pain to
the prophet they were the father-in-law
of the Prophet but they love the prophet
not only more than their daughter they
love the prophet more than their own
life there are many occasions which
occasion you are referring to I don't
know there were occasion when they came
to know that my daughter has caused pain
to the prophet of Allah how dare she
does it they being father they have the
right to slap not you and me for us the
they are the mothers of the Believers
but yet they were human beings even the
wives of the Prophet though they were
wives of the Prophet they are the best
examples yet they were human beings and
they did make mistakes like the Ayah
recited by thear 4 32 they want equal
rights there vers in Surah chap 33 where
the wives of the Prophet tell the
prophet why don't you give us the luxury
of this world they objected why are we
undergoing such a life of poverty so
Allah sends a revelation
if you want this world I will grant it
to you but you will not get
Jenna the ver of the Quran says I will
free you that means if you want I will
let you go free divorce not that he
divorced and you can get the luxury of
this world but you won't get heaven in
the Hereafter and the wives of the
Prophet they repented and they asked for
forgiveness and Allah forgiv them so
here also it's in context and going
against the prophet is more bad than
jumping from
Top jumping from from Top your daughter
will kill herself that's it correct but
going against the prophet is more
bad did you get the answer um sir but my
question still stands I understood your
point I have complete man okay you ask
the question no problem my my question
is uh pretty simple I haven't completed
my answer yet brother all right because
I know your question was in two parts
then you quoted the verse of the Quran
434 yeah and said about wife beating on
to complete that before you answer other
you say I answered
I only answered one part of your
question regarding Hadith the second
part is ofah 4 ver number 34 exactly
after the verse that was recited by the
afterward which
says that the men are the Protectors of
the women the verse says that if they're
disobedient if they're disobedient then
don't talk to
her after that don't share the bed then
the Arabic word is daa means beat her
lightly the Arabic word is beat her
lightly
D be peace with him said when you beat
your wife you should not beat on the
face Point number one point number two
when you beat your wife there should be
no Mark left on a
body and he gave an example beating with
a miswak miswak is
toothbrush in modern way I will say
beating with a
handkerchief handkerchief now if you
beat your wife with
handkerchief it is symbolic it is not
wife bashing wife bashing is not around
in Islam wife bashing means one shot on
the face hit so hard so that the mark
remains she'll remember you for the next
one week or two weeks in Islam wife
bashing is prohibited it is daaba means
beat her lightly that means first you
tell her she's wrong you admonish her
don't share the bed with her ultimatum
last warning beat her lightly now what I
said for any crime committed the
punishment is
same pment is same beating lightly is
not a punishment it's a
warning can you do the
opposite can the daughter hit the father
what if your daughter slaps you will you
like it no why
equality let me complete
man you talk about equality if your
daughter slaps you will you like it no
no there may be occasion when you get
lunatic when you become very old and if
you want to jump and then she slaps you
like with correct though you said no I'm
agreeing you I understand I'm helping
you you understand but you don't
understand me no I I'm helping you okay
if you grow up and you become a lunatic
you become Sile you want to jump from
the 10 story daughter don't to Father
she may have to slap you she's doing in
good faith accept it f now here where a
husband is giving a warning to the wife
if the wife does the same what will the
retaliation be imagine suppose a big
there's a massive person bodybuilder
comes and acts M with you if a small man
come maybe you'll hit him a m person
annar comes and tells you something will
you hit
him will you hit him no though you may
have lot of guts but annar no why
similarly since Allah says in the
previous verse man has been given more
strength than the woman so a physical
warning a symbolic warning a man can
give to a woman a woman can't give to a
man a woman can't there are other
things there are other things she can do
such as such as for example if she has
to cook food in the house it's the duty
of the husband to get Market she can
refuse to cook if you don't get Market I
will not cook she can
object very
well she can object saying I will not
cook it's an
objection on her part if for example
he's not offering Salah offering Salah
is important she can
object nicely with love and affection my
dear husband please offer Salah then she
may get little bit angry also no problem
getting angry with husband is not
allowed unless it's for the sake of
Allah and his rasool but not physical
she can't get physical if she get
physical there will be retaliation it
will never
work imagine your wife SL you will leave
fine you may
say so what you realize this is a
symbolic beating what the Western media
has done they Port as though it's wife
bashing wife bashing you know the also
so because of that
Islam is the best way of life it shows
you how to lead life with your wives
also hope that answer the question if
you have any counter question you're
most welcome brother Yes actually two
points on that primarily the first thing
that is said is a daraba uh which means
basically tapping and as I understand
from the hands word dictionary um the it
comes from the word idb now if you look
at it the Arabic word is used in two
ways one to strike up a poem the word ID
which from which the word Dara is uh
taken out um the first is to strike up a
poem and the second which is used 12
times in the
Quran physical action of striking strike
of
strike up a poem or second strike up a
poem strike up a poem The metaphorically
second part is the physical action of
striking it's used again in uh Surah 812
wherein it um about an angel strike off
their heads strike off the very tips of
their fingers the same word is used so
how can the same word be interpreted
there as lightly but here as good
question the second part part very good
question very good question the second
part is that if we come back to uh sah
buari Volume 7 number
715 again uh the respectable I truly
mean that uh respectable woman Aisha a
great scholar I read about her uh
narrated Aisha said that a lady came
wearing a green whale and complained to
her that is Aisha and showed her a green
spot on her skin caused by beating it
was the Habit at that time for women to
support each other means when they get
beaten up so you support each other so
when Allah's messenger came Aisha said I
have not seen any woman suffering as
much as a believing woman look her skin
is greener than her
clothes that was my second part as for
second part answer first and first part
answer second no problem she's
complaining to the prophet that somebody
has done
Injustice to her it doesn't end saying
the prophet agreed with
it if someone has do Injustice if we
read ahead in some other Hadith the
prophet may have done Justice to her it
doesn't say that someone beat her and
the prophet agreed with it correct she's
just reporting that maybe there is
Injustice done to a woman that's it the
moment she's complaining means she's
disagreeing with it she didn't say
Prophet I heard a very good thing I saw
that the woman were beaten up
the moment she's complaining means the
wife has AA M be with her disapproved of
it so the lesson we get from this is no
one should beat the woman such a way
that she becomes green but sir U see the
exact statements he makes is that I have
not seen any woman that's Aisha herself
it's not my interpretation I have not
seen any woman suffering as much as a
believing woman so we see at the time of
Muhammad uh that women were really in
very very bad shape even though you know
you know that Hadith is saying I have
not seen a person a believing person
like hasz B suffering what was he
suffering from his master tortured him
and said don't say there's one God and I
will leave you has B may Allah be peace
with him on the death Stone he's agreed
to die he will say I will not denounce
Allah I will keep on saying Muhammad
there's no God but Allah and Prophet
Muhammad is the messenger he's taking
the pain
that means if I say hasz B is a Believer
who is being tortured that does not mean
that what act that being done on B may
Allah be peace with him is right it is
wrong but he's a Believer who's taking
the pain in this context we have to see
the context and go to the
Shar you have to seei and what was the
woman was she what was she who tortured
her was it the master was she a slave
woman you have to go to the Shar I'm not
a mad I'm telling you what the answer
can be you have to go to the Shar and
find out why was she who hit her who
beat her did the husband do was the
husband a Believer there are 10,000
reasons but excuse me in mishkat Al
brother Volume Two Brother Sher yes what
I would like you to do there are so many
people waiting at all the mics precisely
concisely i' would like you to put your
question in a few words and then close
because you got such a big sheath of
papers there are many people I see
waiting with small slips or something so
we cannot allow this whole thing to go
on this is not a debate session it's a
question answer session I want you to
put your question in the next four
sentences let Dr Zakir answer so that
all the many ladies standing there here
also get a chance we have exactly 1 hour
12 minutes left we have occupied 20
minutes already brother initially you
asked two question answered you said I
want a counter what counter you gave in
the counter you're asking one more
question I don't mind answering you 100
questions but in this rule one question
at a time go behind the queue no problem
you ask two questions give the answer
you say I a counter question with the
counter question you're asking one more
question so you know I'm very kind I
don't mind I would love after finish you
can come in the cabin and inshallah I
will answer all your question I want to
ask you after I answer your question
what will you do will you believe in the
religion has AA believed yes or no I
have to answer your counter question
well it's not just this one point there
are many many more I'll answer in all
how many are there 10 20 50 100 how many
well we can sit on that how many
approximately well there are many more I
not how many 10 20 100,000 10,000 how
many do you have now in your mind well I
do have how many 10 20 30 how many
probably quite a few maybe quite a few
is how much five or 10 approximately I
don't know maybe 100 questions 100
questions you have brother after the
session is over we sit together okay
write down all the 100 questions
inshallah
inshallah I will try and answer everyone
okay I request you we'll spend the full
night
together I don't mind because you're a
seeker of Truth and I also a seeker of
Truth and my job is to try and clarify
the truth not that I'm a scholar I will
try and answer all your 100 questions
but I doubt whether you'll be able to
write 100 questions I doubt coming to
your main counter question brother that
will be basic counter question counter
question of yours is that daaba has got
two meanings one is stke off the head
you ask me then how do you come to know
which is correct correct exactly in the
counter question don't ask one more
question that mean you're breaking the
rule sir I'm just refuting what you said
not
refuting see you asked the counter
question counter question was of daaba
has got meaning of striking that is a
counter question in that counter
question you asked one more question you
can't can't ask one more question in a
counter question you can ask one counter
question but that was a fresh question
that you asked now coming to your
question of daaba you said striking I
agree with you how do you come to know
one time it is lightly beating one time
it is striking of the head you know the
verse in the Quran is there in
suram Chapter
19 Verse number
47 Mary may Allah be pleased with what
she says when Archangel Gabriel says
that you shall have a son so she says
how shall I have a son when no man has
touched
me how shall I have a son when no man
has touch me now if you go to the L your
hands wear
dictionary all Lanes I believe you read
many dictionaries all this on Internet
it's not difficult you go on the
internet and type you'll get 100
questions against Islam 100 you get
thousand very easy not that a person had
done research if you had done research
You' have come to know who was whose
father and who was his husband and
mother everything but you go on the
internet you get this very easy now the
Arabic word masah has got two meanings
physical touch it means sexual touch so
when Mary Mel be pleased with her she
says how shall I have a son when no man
has touched me it is understood it is
not physical touch it is sexual touch
correct yes
similarly there are several vers in the
Quran now when there are two three
meanings even both can be correct or one
can be correct to have more details you
go to the Hadith Hadith is the
commentary of the verse of the
Quran
correct maybe the same word has got two
meaning in that verse it means meaning
number one in the second verse it
meaning number two Hadith is the
commentary so when we go to the Hadith
of this Sur 4:34 talking about daaba
there the prophet said do not beat on
the
face do not leave a mark beat like a
toothbrush I gave the answer but you
were so much concentrating on the notes
you have that you forgot my answer if
you have heard my answer that if there
are two three meanings all meanings may
not be
right maybe one is right maybe two are
right maybe all three are right
therefore you have to go back to the
prophet the Quran
says obey Allah and obey the messenger
so when there are two three meanings you
have to go to the Hadith and find out
what did the prophet mean by that word
so they when say strikes off that it
means of here it means strike lightly so
therefore if you know the supplement the
commentary of the Quran it's the Hadi
without the authentic Hadith you cannot
understand Islam so a prophet said it
means beat lightly like beating with a
toothbrush don't beat on the face don't
leave a mark on the body so these are
the guidance given BYO therefore it is
obligatory that besides the Quran you
have to follow the authentic Hadith hope
that answer the question and inshallah
I'll wait for you after 10:00 in the
speakers launch inshallah yes brother
Sher thank you and and since you have
two daughters you said you have two
daughters and you want sorry and one son
the son there's no Hadith saying the son
will take you to jna here if he become
the pious son and if he prays for you
inshallah he will be a path to Jenna
what I want I want to see to it that
besides Good Deeds you even have
faith faith is one of the important
criteria to go to Jenna and since you
have an urge to go to Jenna to Paradise
inshallah I pray to Allah subhana tala
may he make me the zya the pathway to
take you to J
inshallah yes sister hi my name is Chloe
I'm from Canada I'm a student here in
Mumbai and my question is uh why women
are not accepted into mosque in
India sister asked a very good question
that why are women not accepted in the
MOs in India so India has to blame not
the Quran and Hadith I told in my
lecture do not judge Islam by looking at
what the Muslims do or what the Muslim
Society does Judge Islam according to
the Quran and the
say our beloved Prophet M wasallam said
there aith inkari the prophet said do
not prevent the female Servants of Allah
from going to the
mosque another inkari volume number one
in the book of Salah just a few Hadith
before that he said that if the female
servants that means the Muslim women
Servants of Allah if they want to go to
the mosque at night do not prevent them
now it is the Indian culture now when we
allow a woman to go in the MTH we see to
it that she gets equal but separate
facilities separate entrance separate
place of ablution wo separate place of
prayer we don't believe in intermingling
like when you go to the church or when
you go to the temple why because in our
Salah sister when we pray we believe in
equality of human beings We Stand
shoulder Tosh shoulder irrespective
whether the man next to me he's black or
white yellow or brown king or popper I
stand close to him shoulder Tosh
shoulder now if a lady is there close to
me shoulder Tosh shoulder the medical
doctors tell me the temperature of the
lady is 1° higher if I pray standing
with her shoulder Tosh shoulder I will
concentrate more on her than Allah
subhana ta'ala therefore separate but
equal facility separate entrance
separate place of wo you have to wash
yourself wash your legs you can't do in
front of the namam so in India most of
the mosque don't have but alhamdulillah
it has started I know of several mosque
in Bombay where they have facilities for
ladies we have several mosque in South
India where I've been today but I do
agree with you it is very Less in
percentage if you go to Saudi Arabia
almost all the mosque more than 95% of
the mosque they have facility for women
more than 95 whether it's 99 99.9 I
don't know more than 95% of the MTH have
separate facility for ladies you go to
London you go to USA most of the foreign
it is India so the problem is with the
Indian Muslims therefore in my talk I
say that see to it there should be a
separate facility for the
women separate but equal fa so that they
two can pray to almighty God in the Moss
hope that answer the question sister
thank you you're most welcome
yes brother good evening sir my name is
Ashish and my question is there is
concept in Islam by paying money to the
victim's family by paying money to
victim's family from accused family and
getting released from the crime what is
the concept behind that and is it not
Injustice with the victim's
family brother asked the question that
what is the concept of diamani mean
blood money in Islam that if someone has
murdered someone or killed someone
whatever reason the family members of
the person who's murdered can
excuse can excuse by taking the money
this concept is that if someone driving
a
car or maybe by mistake while walking
something
happens or by accident someone dies here
if it is out of negligence
yet for example doctor is doing surgery
and this proven out of negligence the
patient has died Islamic law death
penalty but there the relatives of the
person who has died fine we agree the
Nia was good he didn't actually kill my
son I forgive him but
negligence if it is done while trying to
save a life he goes cot free but if
negligently he does something
and the person
dies then death penalty because his
fault in this
case if it's proven it is 100%
negligence then the family members may
say even if it's negligence I forgive
him okay I forgive him like free I
forgive him by taking one rupee or by
the 1 million rupees maybe that 1
million rupee may be a penalty okay
don't do it again now you have done it I
don't want to take your life I forgive
you 1 million rupees a penalty so this
concept in Islam that the person who has
died his family members can forgive by
asking a penalty if it is a
conspiracy and a murder 100 person
proven then it is death penalty these
cases are mainly when we know that the
person has a chance to be forgiven if
someone goes and does a Bomb Blast on
the street and kills 100 people
innocent people no forgiving death
penalty direct you understand now for
example while if you're doing something
maybe a building is being constructed
fine and the negligence the worker gets
electrocuted it's the fault of the
Builder now the family members say okay
I don't mind forgiving you know my
husband used to give me every day 2,000
Rupees now if I demand 500,000 Rupees
even his full life how much could he
give me 25,000 a year
5 lakh would take how many
years how many 20 years so now if I take
that 5 lakh rupees I can invest it
somewhere and get 4,000 rupes 5,000
rupes a month correct so fine I forgive
him and with this money at least I can
survive the various aspects that angle
this is not the only aspect I'm giving
you examples so in this way what happens
at least in Indian law finish death
penalty does the government take care of
him
the earning member has died the wife and
children on the
street does the government help no so
here at least as a compensation now they
invest the money every month they get
5,000 rupees so at least some part of
their life is taken care of it may not
compensate
completely and sometimes the person may
just forgive without taking money
also so therefore the are various
situation Islam has permitted so that
it's beneficial for both hope that
answer the question yes brother and
kindly have your questions on wom's
rights the topic of the day
please Shalom I'm Dany uh I'm a student
I read Bible studying more about the
biblical manners understanding and I do
read uh Muslim
books uh now I'm not relating to all the
question what Bible and Quran has uh
this is something related to my friend
who is my best friend his name is don't
want to take it sorry now he is married
and due to some reason uh he is uh
planning to divorce his wife and I
finded out that that was a very small
reason that he want to divorce his
wife and secondly uh yesterday I was
just reading this Mumbai miror at midday
that 112 years old guy Muhammad from
somal he's getting married of sorry get
got married to this 13-year-old girl
safia and I was very disturbed to answer
my friend because I just asked one of my
friend and he told this is what we learn
and this is what we return and this is
what we follow so I just went on to the
internet as is that this is the easiest
way I see because I don't get a chance
like Zakir brother for you to question
it so just I'll just read it for you if
you give me a chance to read it from uh
what I found from the internet regarding
this uh justification and the
relationship which Muhammad had is that
a true or you just help me how to come
out of this issue and I can go to my
friend and say that this is what exactly
the Quran teaches I'll read do you want
to read or do you want me to answer I'll
just read it first for you but you un
satisfied with the answer now uh
whatever you may say hope I answer
question not I give you the answer so
what the paper says forget about it okay
if you satisfied with the answer what
you have in your hand then that's
sufficient if you're not satisfied I'll
give you the answer directly uh just let
me read it okay okay take care problem
brother put it in just five sentences in
precise form otherwise don't read it
I'll do I'll do that for you sir uh this
is actually let me just quote it from
sah bukari Volume 7 book number 62 which
uh uh zabir Bin Abdullah
says uh when he got married uh Haz
Muhammad says what type of lady have you
married replied I'm married to a metan
he said
Muhammad why don't you have a liking for
a virgins and for fondling them zabir
also said Haz Muhammad said why don't
you marry a young girl so that you might
play with her and she with
you now it's a I was like little bit
disturbed this is the preference of Haz
Muhammad or after reading bukari volume
number five he says interested in
reading the Hadith rather than the
question you posed Hallelujah correct
now I just you ask a question I give you
the answer you want to read the answer
of somebody else because you want to
quote theith quot directly because I get
an answer from you also that's why I'm
quoting it if you have 2 plus two I
don't know the answer I want to tell
what other people said why you bother
I'll give you the answer directly it is
four what other people said S 8 10
forget about it and that's why I came
over here sir that's the reason why you
reading somebody else's answer if you're
not satisfied okay correct yeah that
means I have to comment on both on the
question as well as the answer
correct okay I'll do both no problem see
what is the ni important if your Nia was
to get the answer why Muhammad 112 years
old 113 years old MAA 13 years old the
answer have given you but you also
wanted the answer of prophet Muhammad
correct yes because directly what do you
have to say I'm not satisfied with the
answer given on the internet given on
the paper directly ask the question on
the Hadith rather than beating around
the bush I'll give both the answers okay
I'll give the answers hope I may
satisfied with your answers too
inshallah inshah that depends upon you
if I said two play equal to four you
said no it is five I can't help it I'll
I'll take it what you say but I'll
believe what I can believe it sure sure
you have to believe what you believe you
can't believe what I believe until you
believe what I believe true sir because
it's not law of contradiction sorry
please go ahead sorry what did you say
please go ahead because I want to know
the answer from you as far as Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him is concerned
fine I'll come to it later on regarding
the Man by the name of Muhammad you said
no yeah because it's some person from
African country Somalia from Somalia 112
years old you said yeah married a girl
of 13 years old yes sir and is a fifth
marriage fifth marriage fifth marriage
not not five together maybe when he
married and divorced I said
the at any given time you can't have
more than four now coming to the answer
why in
Islam you can marry a woman the moment
she gets matured if she reaches puberty
you can marry that is Islam fine a woman
to marry for a man the moment reaches
puberty till he
dies he can marry anyone choice is
his would you marry a woman 15 years
older to you no no your choice but the
prophet Muhammad married his choice okay
Prophet Muhammad at the age of 25
married a woman KH with her who was 40
years
old you will not marry I will not tell
you you have to marry it's your choice
now he wanted to marry a woman 15 years
or older to her because she was Pious
who are we to object he's willing and
the woman is
willing because wait wait let me answer
please don't interrupt you POS the
question I said sorry sir yes and accept
it no problem
so the husband and wife who are we to
object that woman wants to cover her
head you said don't cover the head why
she wants to cover ahead and the
president of France said women should
not cover that why he wants to enjoy
seeing women you can go on the Miami
Beach why does he want to do it in
France does it make sense subjugating
that woman doesn't feel subjugated he's
feeling subjugated why he's feeling
subjugate because he cannot enjoy women
he cannot enjoy the lust so the problem
is in him not in the woman covering the
head but the man is 112 years old
Medical Science tells us even a man of
112 years can
procreate can give birth to a child true
yes sir yes I'm a medical doctor now he
wants to marry a 13-year-old girl who
has reached puberty what is your problem
you don't give your daughter to him who
no don't give I'm I telling you am I
telling your sister to marry him no no
if the parents also agreed and the girl
agreed she may be liking that man 112
years what a Pious man reminds me of the
sahaba I sacrifice everything because
our beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
Al wasallam said that if you marry a
spouse you look for four things virtue
nobility wealth and Beauty the best
among this is virtue and if a woman of
13 years old finds a virtuous man of 112
years I would prefer if I know he's
virtuous if I know not any Tom can Harry
I would not mind giving my daughter if I
know that he's a virtuous man and will
see to it that he takes my daughter to
Jenna I would not mind but after
verifying he's such a virtuous man
remind me of the saah the caliber of
Omar Abu Bakr us hasz Ali may Allah be
pleased with them
all why not but today we see more for
beauty more for wealth I'm not saying
that the man of Somalia was virtuous I
don't know I don't know but can it be
possible yes chances are less can it be
possible yes chances are less why not if
the girl is willing therefore I said in
my talk the marriage can only solize if
if the man and woman agree that does not
mean tomorrow a man even know 50 years
come then ask my daughter I will not
give if I said he's as virtuous as as
the
I cannot find a better match I cannot
find I cannot find a better match what
you have to realize that maybe that girl
found that man to be virtuous maybe I
don't know I haven't interviewed her I
haven't interviewed him maybe that man
found that girl virtuous I don't know so
if the man and the woman agreeing who
are you and me to interfere why are we
trying to interfere their rights now you
may have married a girl I don't know
good or bad you may think think she's
beautiful someone may think she's
ugly and someone says why have you
married her sorry I'm not getting
personal your wife may be beautiful
mallah but someone comes and objects why
have you married ugly woman you will say
what is bothering you I find her to be
beautiful who are you to interfere will
you get angry or not will you get angry
or not beauty is subjective someone
comes and tells you oh brother whatever
your name
is you know your wife is so ugly you
said you mind your own business that's
my wife why are you interfering if
somebody comes and criticize is your
wife that is your
choice so as far as that 112 year Somali
man is concerned and the 13- year girl
is concerned chances is very negligible
0 1% but if both agree who are we to
interfere coming to the answer of
prophet mm sallallah Al wasallam that
why don't you marry a younger woman
virgin woman the prophet may be knowing
how that saaha is there's a person who
came and said that while I'm fasting can
I kiss my wife the prophet said yes you
can another SAA comes can I kiss my wife
the prophet said no so the sa said first
one you said yes second one you said no
why because he knew that the first man
could control his desires while fasting
even after kissing the wife he will not
go beyond that the second person once he
kisses his wife he will break his fast
he will go beyond that Prophet knew you
don't know I don't know similarly the
prophet may be knowing that if he
marries a matr maybe yet he will go
after Beauty the prophet advises him but
what did the prophet do the first woman
he married was 15 years older to him 15
years which you wouldn't like doing you
just told me that correct yes so the
prophet he knows because he found p in
khad may Allah be pleased with her
therefore she's one of the four P women
in the world so the prophet knows like I
being a doctor I may give one medicine
one person second person second medicine
you ask why am I changing medicine
because I'm a doctor I know you not a
doctor so the prophet gives different
advice to different people depending
upon the situation you don't know what
prophet knows and do you think what the
prophet said is wrong is Right some
people may like younger girl some people
may like older girl so what you have to
realize that it is nothing wrong it is
advice given by the prophet did he say
something which is wrong no perfectly
right but see he's like style all the
women he married except for one only one
was virgin all of them they were either
divorcees or they were
widowed uh sir actually it's not liking
or unliking getting married to you ask
me the question I give the reply I'm
asking the question someone objects but
how does Quran relate to this people
simple question which people these
people those who are getting married in
this particular they're liking or don't
liking they like something says do not
inherit women against a wishes Surah NAA
4: 19 but if the woman wants and the man
wants who are you and I to
prevent who are you and I to prevent
what is bothering you I'm asking the
question if he finds pety in that young
lady and that young lady finds py in
that elderly man what is bothering you
and me tell me that is it UNM medical
no can they procreate yes what's the
problem imagine someone comes and tells
you why have you married a black woman
why have you married a white woman I
mean that's your choice in Islam a woman
becoming black or white does not make a
superior inferior what the prophet said
the best is virtue now why did the man
of Somalia at the age of 112 married 13
I don't know I'm least bothered to know
is it logical yes chances are very less
possible same thing what the prophet
advice so I'm asking you the question if
the girl and the boy are AG green why
are you interfering with the choice is
my question do you have a right to
interfere is my question I'm asking you
a question do you have a right to
interfere when the husband and wife are
doing something which they like it's not
going against the Quran it is not even
juping your rights So my answer yes sir
again is their liking or not liking I'm
not interfering in them they may like
112 years old old man or 13 years but my
thing is how this Quran
words related to this people like they
are doing it what they doing it did you
hear my answer the reason for criteria
to get married is you should reach
puberty have they reach puberty or not
can a 13-year-old girl reach puberty yes
or no do you know the answer no can she
reach puberty uh 13
years you don't know you're doctor sir
please tell me in India yes sir in Delhi
the report came if a girl reaches
puberty by the age of 10 nothing to be
worried about age of 10 also it's very
common many girls hundreds of girls who
are less than 39 they have reached
puberty many it's not common so once you
reach puberty finish you may have
preference okay the Indian law says 18
years Indian law Indian law if he was an
Indian it would have been illegal
according to the Indian law America say
16 years now who's right America or
India I'm asking you the question 16
years or 18 years who is Right according
to their law
ah
law is according to the quranic law very
good answer this is very good answer the
problem is that when America says 16 you
have no
problem when Quran says 13 what is your
problem I didn't say no problem you can
fin no problem thank you then you got
the answer Quran says as long as they
agree there is no problem in Texas in
Texas the American law says a woman
should be minimum 16 years old in India
if a 16y old girl gets married illegal
Haram prohibited in Texas because the
Texans they marry at early age there's a
special law for women of Texas at the
age of 14 they can get
married now what's the answer do you
agree with the woman of 14 years in
Texas to get married right or wrong
again I said sir it's the their law
their law correct who are you to object
I didn't I'm asking a question in
America if a 115 year old man marries a
14y old girl is it allowed or not in
Texas allowed so when Texas
allows so why can't the Quran allow it
may not go down your throat no problem
you don't marry I don't know whether you
live till 11 12 years old on no I don't
want to be but even if you live if you
don't want to marry it's your choice it
is the choice of an individual this is
the right word Islam has given which you
want to take away from man and woman
Islam has given that right they have the
right to choose Brother May the peace of
Jesus Christ be with you sir
brother as far as if you say may Jesus
Christ be with me I follow the teachings
of Jesus Christ peace be upon him you
say shalam alum it's a verse of the
Bible from the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 shalom shalom it is shalam
alum it's not Shalom peace be with you
sir it is shalam alum it's not Shalom
the same it is shalam shalam alum means
it's not only Shalom I'm giving you the
reference Bible Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 verse number 36 it is
shum shum shalam alum in Hebrew in
arabicum May peace be on you yes brother
but when you said that may Jesus be with
me in what in teachings or in what as
far as teachings are concerned Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said in the
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 12- 14 I have many things to say
unto you but he cannot Bey them now for
even the spirit of TR shall come he
shall guide you unto all Truth for he
shall glorify me he shall tell you
things to come Prophet Jesus peace be
upon him said there is another Messenger
to come and his name will be Muhammad
peace be upon him so I'm following the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him that's the reason I'm following the
teachings of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him if you don't want to follow the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him it is your problem you can refer to
my video cassette similarities between
Islam and Christianity you'll get more
information for any question you can go
behind the queue and ask me brother
please go behind the queue and you can
ask me brother yes
sister hi my name is Meredith and I'm a
student studying Psychology from Canada
uh my question is very simple uh how can
you say that men and women that there's
no sexism when the very setup of this
conference is sexist for example the men
are seated can you repeat the question
slowly sister yes why is it that the men
are seated in front of the women um the
very structure of this conference is
sexist why is
that Mah sister asked a very good
question that why aren't the woman
seated in front no why are we not if
you're going to separate us how come
we're not left to the right correct why
is one in front of the other question
that why are the women if you believe in
equal why not left and right why not
it's a very good question sister because
the Quran says in Sur chapter number 24
vers number 30 say to the believing man
that he should lower his gaze and guard
his modesty whenever a man looks at a
woman any thought comes in his mind he
should lower his gaze now if the women
are sitting on my right I will only have
to speak looking on the
left you know because I can look at them
yeah I can look at everyone this I
cannot see your face also from here you
may look at my direction if you want to
see me Clos you can see on the screen
there no problem but for me the Quran
says the moment I look at a woman I
should lower my gift unless she's my
wife or she's my mother she's my
daughter and if someone says that
someone looks at a woman and nothing
happens to him then he requires a
psychiatrist
so if you were here I'll would talk to
you like that so you'll tell me what an
manner is this you know showing me his
back now my gaze is there knowing the
microphone I cannot see you I can just
see okay just little bit here and there
so I'm maintaining my hijab now when we
have lady speakers speaking only ladies
front row no problem so what happened
because it's a gen
speaking there are occasions some
occasions then we have to keep a
partition and we can do that that and we
have done that but there such a vast
Gathering so many cameras it will
obstruct so that's the reason but in no
way are we trying to say that the woman
are inferior that the reason you have
got a screen close to you mashallah
especially for sisters are sitting a bit
more behind so you can get the view but
in front it will be difficult for me to
speak for me to maintain my hijab for me
to look because in public speaking you
know we are taught we have to look at
the audience if the audience is a woman
in front of me you know I remember once
i' had gone to the gulf
country and I was called for a talk and
know ladies
organization I always say at least the
front row should be gent you know but
they didn't do it so half the talk I
gave looking at the ground and balance
off looking at the ceiling down ceiling
believe me I was in
hell not because I was in company of
ladies I was in hell because half my
lecture I gave looking at the ground and
half my lecture looking in the ceiling I
had to maintain my hijab here I can I
can talk to the person I can look at him
I can stare at him if he's sleeping I
stare at him you stop sleeping you
know the public
speaking but with the ladies therefore
far it is for maintaining the hijab so
that's the reason sister it is not at
all in any way trying to belittle them
and the reason we have given you one
microphone instead of two because we
feel that the proportion is
approximately 1/3 2/3 that's the reason
but but the moment last time when there
were more ladies we gave equal
proportion hope that answer the question
sister thank you